make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I don't think we've done this
yet we're gonna be covering blue marvel
Adam Brashear now Adam Brashear is a not
even really obscure but like a painfully
underrated hero right like so the story
is like the legend the blue marvel the
actual story is one of the best stories
of Marvel Comics that so few people know
about so the way this worked out is that
there have been different instances over
the course of Marvel Comics where a
writer comes along and introduces a hero
and says like they existed before
everybody else now that was the nature
of the nature behind this century Robert
Reynolds he was the old-school superhero
who appeared before the Fantastic Four
and the x-men incredible alcohol that
kind of stuff and he's the one who
inspired them to become heroes but the
idea behind blue Marvel is that he was
back in the day like a hero who popped
up but basically disappeared off the
radar and like nobody seems to have
known about him now in reality Marvel
and Kevin Grove oh the guy who created
him
they don't really reconcile that right
in your stand why here in a second so
the idea behind blue Marvel is okay
there was a guy named Adam Brashear who
is basically like a physicist
essentially alongside a guy named Connor
Sims and what had happened was they had
been working on an experiment and what
the experiment did is it basically
tapped into the negative zone right like
antimatter so think of it as like a
mirror version of like all the existing
universes that exist out there it's just
the opposite of them in terms of the
matter it contains it gets kind of weird
and really crazy when it comes to like
theoretical physics and so on but
basically the only thing you need to
know is that if positive matter were to
interact with negative matter meaning
like if they hit each other and created
like an explosive effect they would
basically eradicate everything in
existence it's kind of crazy when it
comes to antimatter but the fact remains
that what it basically happened here is
through their experiment that is
essentially like tapped into antimatter
and what that meant was that from that
point going forward Adam Brashear was
powered by it and so in effect on
embrasure is powered by the end like all
the energy that makes up the negative
zone like all the energy that makes up a
universe basically he's like powered by
a universe so it's like being powered by
the Infinity Gauntlet minus all the
reality warping on an extreme degree the
difference is that he's part he's
basically he's powered by an antimatter
by antimatter an antimatter universe
meaning he has like extreme reality
manipulation if he walked into like the
negative zone because literally he can
control everything inside that universe
because he's powered by it
he's like one with that universe so to
speak but because the main Marvel
Universe is positive matter universe it
limits his abilities to a degree now
what this means is that going forward in
the Marvel Universe when it came to Adam
following this experiment he basically
became like a superhero and he literally
fought against all these different
threats and so on it was it was pretty
cool to see it pop up the issue with
this was that the way the story was
written at the time it was basically the
1960s and so what this meant was that
the the country was in a state of like
extreme racism right like you literally
had just racism everywhere like it like
you know it was the civil rights
movement and so what ended up happening
is an embrasure kind of stood up and
said like I don't side with African
Americans I don't side with like white
Americans I'm here to just protect the
world but the fear of the federal
government was that he would side with
African Americans and essentially topple
the government because what would they
be able to do to stop and there's
nothing they could do to stop him
because he was so powerful and he would
basically see the ruin of the feds and
so what ended up happening is the city
President Kennedy basically asked him to
like accept the presidential like this
this super high in presidential medal
and then stepped down which is what an
embrasure did following that like all
records of his existence were stripped
from the books like nobody knew he was
there another question that kind of has
to be asked here this is sort of this
never really reconciled by Marvel is if
if Adam Brashear did things like save
the world from meteors and if like he
was a superhero that was recognized the
world round then how come like Tony
Stark as a kid never heard of him or hug
him there was no reference to him before
that like like before the Fantastic Four
showed up like when they showed up why
isn't it like no I had heard about him
up until this point even if only by like
word-of-mouth right like you would think
somebody would be walking around and be
like whatever happened in that blue
Marvel guy who was a superhero like
twenty years ago like whatever happened
to him but like nobody nobody ever asked
that question it was one of those weird
things that Marvel never bothered a
fixer or really reconcile or anything
but essentially when it comes to Adam
Brashear one ended up happening after
this is basically like Connor Sims
showed back up but Connor Sims where an
embrasure was able to channel antimatter
energy Connor Sims was an antimatter
energy and so basically in a lot of ways
like he was more powerful than blue
Marvel the issue is that he couldn't
show up in the main Marvel Universe
consistently he was trying to make his
return but he would pop up occasionally
and when he did he would wreak havoc on
everybody right like there's one point
where like this century and where iron
man and black widow and like a full
contingent of the Avengers take on
Connor Sims and he crushes them all like
his it's one of the one of the most
insane things that you're ever gonna see
when it comes to his character and the
issue with this is that as the story
came to an end and you ended up having
like an overseer versus Connor sims
because Connor Sims is essentially pure
antimatter energy blue Marvel literally
just like siphon that energy off of him
and destroyed the form it was
existing in the main Marvel Universe and
like that was the end of him Riley he
was basically a nonentity he's kind of
floated out there and that's all there
was but in terms of the power that blue
Marvel possesses especially when it
comes to like Al Ewing's Ultimates
essentially he's got like all your
regular superhero strength ability right
so like like basically the Superman ESCA
Billy super strength super speed
durability flight all that kind of stuff
what differentiates him is that because
he does he is able to manipulate
antimatter energy he can also manipulate
positive matter energy not in the sense
that he's like a universe wide you know
reality manipulator but in the sense
that he can still like kind of
manipulate energy on a fundamental scale
he's got cosmic awareness meaning he
knows everything that's going on in the
universe and in actually during aliens
Ultimates he basically transcended that
level to where he was able to understand
everything going on beyond the universe
if only slightly enough to understand
that like there was another universe out
there you know there was there was
basically something that was like
controlling the main Marvel Universe
right lil I had that universe and
changed it was weird it was kind of a
weird story you'll find the link down in
the description for the Ultimates run
which will make it and it'll make a lot
more sense once you get through it but
essentially blue Marvel is is like very
Superman esque in terms of his abilities
but also he's like a genius in terms of
his intelligence too so on and so forth
so if blue Marvel shows up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what does this mean
for the superheroes okay he's not
indestructible but he would be super
difficult to defeat so Thor would fall
to blue Marvel The Incredible Hulk they
could probably fight for a while but the
longer the Incredible Hulk fights the
stronger he gets right so it's one of
those things where if blue Marvel
strength supersedes the incredible
Hulk's base level strength and the fight
ends quickly then the incredible hulks
is done everybody else is really kind of
out the window this savior of it all
would come in the form of Tony Stark and
the reason why is because Tony Stark
would essentially analyze him and say
hey look this guy basically like
manipulates antimatter energy so cut him
off from antimatter energy take away his
ability to siphon that energy and he's
nothing more than a normal guy and
that's what it would take as literally
what it would come down to now that's
entirely possible especially when it
comes to someone like Doctor Strange
because if Tony Stark can use Doctor
Strange as a means to basically
understand how the negative zone works
assuming that it's even introduced in
the MCU and understand like the ability
for blue Marvel to tap into the negative
zone using the knowledge of Tony Stark
then the two of them working in tandem
can in turn basically use dr. Strange's
power to cut off blue Marvel's access to
another dimension and then in turn like
the Avengers will just kind of go
through and basically like imprison him
or whatever you know I mean it'll take a
while for
energy to kind of siphon off right so
it's like the heat of the earth I guess
the earth was knocked out of the sun's
orbit it something the earth was just
suddenly freeze right it's not like old
man the Sun is like a hundred more miles
away well we're all just gonna freeze up
it would take a while for the heat
inside the earth to dissipate because of
the atmosphere it'd be the exact same
thing with blue Marvel right like it
would take time for the antimatter
energy in his body to kind of siphon off
and basically begin to sort of go away
until it gets to the point where he's
just an old guy that's easily defeated
that's really all it is but his super
intelligence comes into play in a sense
that he could easily predict that in an
intern take measures to basically ensure
that he would survive but that's kind of
the caveat here is because I have a hard
time believing a scenario where blue
marble would show up and become a bad
guy it may be one of those things worse
like an early misunderstanding where
it's like hey look like you know I
didn't mean you know I'm not a bad guy
here like I'm a good guy here there's
something else going on but it kind of
creates an interesting situation because
then what you could do is you could say
like Connor Sims is the basis behind it
now if blue Marvel wasn't part of the
equation and Connor Sims was there well
then it becomes a whole different
scenario because they would all die like
none of the heroes of the main model in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe could
stand against Connor Sims because he's
just so powerful he would easily be able
to crush everybody they're up to and
including for theros the whole nine
yards all of them would fall to Connor
Sims but in the moment focusing on blue
Marvel he would tear them all apart limb
by limb
assuming that like Tony Stark wasn't
able to figure out that he was basically
a guy that tapped into antimatter energy
then like The Incredible Hulk will be
like the first person that blue Marvel
would go after right because the
Incredible Hulk has unlimited strength
who would be like okay you know if I
start killing everybody around Bruce
Banner he's gonna like get angrier and
angrier and the Hulk's gonna start
getting angrier and angrier and like
literally like he'll end up destroying
me so take Bruce Banner out in the
Incredible Hulk out as fast as you can
and then from there focus on everybody
else like like Thor does not have
unlimited power Thor can go into a
berserker rage but that only amplifies
his power so far and so if that's the
case like then literally have like Thor
be the next one taken out and then
everybody else is right for the pickings
I mean Parker being run in this cool but
that frothy oh that that faux hawks not
gonna save him and like Black Widow
she's not gonna be able to do anything
because she can shoot guns literally
nobody else would be able to stop him
like Captain America would die like the
whole nine yards they would all die
against blue Marvel
because one he's so intelligent and -
he's just so powerful so again like it
creates an interesting scenario when
you're talking about a guy with that
level of power because you would think
looking at the outset that he be easily
defeated or even if
easily defeated that the fight wouldn't
drag on that long that you know it would
be what he sees works like okay we can
kind of push it to the limit but
ultimately the heroes would win not at
all because despite how obscure he may
seem he is exceedingly powerful in his
abilities brute strength speed
durability you know his intelligence
some minor matter manipulation in the
main Marvel Universe extreme matter
manipulation in the negative zone it
gets kind of bonkers when you're talking
about that level of power but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]